Donc simplement, on se redresse le corps jusqu'au sommet de la tête.
Et de nouveau, placez votre attention sur la partie basse du corps en vous détendant du mieux que vous pouvez.
Donc, après, maintenant, nous plaçons notre attention sur la respiration.
Dans cette tradition, on préfère placer l'attention sur la respiration dans le corps.
Mais si vous avez déjà une habitude bien établie de...
Et faire attention à la respiration au niveau des narines, c'est bon.
Et puis, posez votre attention avec douceur sur la sensation douce de la respiration, son processus.
Et alors que l'abdomen se soulève, nous pouvons dire « se soulève » et quand il s'abaisse, dire « s'abaisse ».
Donc ne dites pas cela avant
Avant la respiration, faites-le vraiment la petite note mentale en même temps que l'acte lui-même, sinon cela donnera une impression de contrôle de la respiration.
si l'esprit vagabonde dès que vous vous en apercevez reconnaissez et prenez conscience de l'état d'esprit qui conduit l'esprit à s'en aller de ce qu'il y a derrière planning planning
Par exemple, planifiez, planifiez, s'inquiétez, s'inquiétez.
Vous pouvez répéter dans ce cas-là, vous vous apercevez, vous répétez le mot.
Et puis, ramenez votre attention sur la respiration.
Ressentez-vous un peu doux-minded, doux-minded, continuez de lever la cheville.
Si vous vous sentez endormi ou somnolent ou léthargique, vous passez votre temps à vous redresser la colonne vertébrale.
Vous pouvez aussi ouvrir les yeux et maintenir l'attention à l'intérieur.
Vous pouvez même vous mettre debout.
en laissant votre attention sur les sensations douces provoquées par la respiration, leur permettant de réduire au silence l'esprit, d'apporter le calme au cœur,
La tranquillité, l'immobilité au corps.
S'élever, s'abaisser.
Si l'esprit vagabonde, dès que vous vous en apercevez, reconnaissez et prenez conscience de l'énergie qui conduit l'esprit à vagabonder ainsi.
Qu'est-ce qu'il y a derrière cette pensée ?
Laissez tomber l'histoire.
On s'intéresse seulement à l'attitude, à l'humeur, à l'énergie de l'émotion.
Irritation, irritation.
Et on répète par des petits mots ce dont il s'agit, qu'on a remarqué par exemple, irritation, irritation.
Romance, romance.
Imagination romantique, imagination romantique.
Et puis ramener l'attention sur la respiration.
Vous vous sentez endormi, fatigué ?
Eh bien, redressez la colonne, ouvrez les yeux, levez-vous.
As we begin to feel more focused, see if you can draw closer to the breath.
Alors que nous commençons à être plus focalisés, regardez si vous pouvez vous approcher davantage de la respiration.
Est-ce qu'on est capable de voir le tout début de l'inspire et de rester jusqu'à sa fin ?
voir le début de l'expire et rester jusqu'à sa toute fin.
Si vous sentez des tensions quand vous faites cela,
Remettez-vous à l'intérieur de vous-même et ayez l'impression de recevoir la respiration.
Alors que nous commençons à être plus concentrés, à avoir une attention plus stable, nous pouvons nous ouvrir à ce qui appelle notre attention, en dehors de la respiration.
Si c'est un son, notre attention va vers l'oeil.
un son, alors notre attention va sur les oreilles.
On ne s'intéresse pas à l'explication au sujet de ce qui cause ce son.
On s'intéresse au processus de l'écoute et de l'entendre.
et on peut répéter intérieurement entendre entendre c'est une sensation dans le corps provoquée par le corps comme par exemple une démangeaison l'envie de se gratter go to it feel it
allez dans la sensation ressentez-la faites-en une expérience intime et vous pouvez répéter intérieurement deux fois une description de ce qui se passe se gratter se gratter enfin démangeaison démangeaison pas se gratter justement
Mais si c'est vraiment terrible, vous pouvez vous gratter.
Et vous dites, se gratter, se gratter.
Et observer comment le cœur se calme.
Si c'est un ressenti dans le corps causé par une émotion
C'est un ressenti dans le corps provoqué par une émotion.
Alors, allez porter votre attention au ressenti de l'émotion.
Faites-en une expérience intime.
Anxieté.
Et vous pouvez répéter pareil deux fois ce qui se passe.
Anxiété, anxiété.
Joie, joie.
Et regardez si vous pouvez attendre jusqu'à ce que cela commence à disparaître.
Et s'il n'y a rien qui attire votre attention, alors vous retournez à la respiration.
Peut-être que vous ne retournerez pas une seule fois à la respiration pendant tout le reste de l'assise.
La respiration, c'est votre ancrage, votre point de départ.
C'est l'endroit où vous revenez toujours quand vous n'avez rien qui attire votre attention et également l'endroit où vous revenez quand vous êtes dans un état de confusion.
On commence avec la respiration.
S'élever, s'abisser.
en devenant conscients de la manière dont nous réagissons à ce dont nous faisons l'expérience.
Quand quelque chose est agréable, nous sommes attirés par cette chose.
Nous voulons la préserver, la continuer et qu'elle croisse.
Et quand quelque chose est désagréable, on a tendance à le rejeter.
à essayer de trouver quelque chose pour nous en divertir, pour ne pas y penser et à vouloir que cela cesse.
Ce sont ces deux sortes de désirs, dit le Bouddha, qui causent notre souffrance.
Est-ce que c'est vrai ?
Tout ce dont nous faisons l'expérience survient et disparaît.
Les sensations arrivent et s'en vont.
Les émotions surviennent et disparaissent.
Les pensées, les images traversent l'esprit.
Rien ne se répète.
Chaque respiration est similaire mais pas la même.
Rien ne demeure.
Est-ce qu'il y a quelque chose sur lequel nous pouvons nous reposer ?
À laquelle nous pouvons nous fier ?
Quand nous pratiquons Vipassana, nous nous mettons dans un poste d'observation.
De cette position, de cette position intérieure, nous pouvons voir, nous pouvons ressentir ce qui se passe dans cet organisme.
De cette position, nous pouvons voir, nous pouvons ressentir tout ce qui survient dans notre univers intérieur.
Les sensations, les émotions, les pensées sont toutes des objets.
Il y a une distance entre l'observer et l'observateur.
Il y a une distance entre l'observateur et l'observé, celui qui ressent et ce qui est ressenti.
Celui qui fait l'expérience et ce qui est expérimenté.
Vous pouvez faire cela plus clair à vous-même en mettant le mot « là ».
Et vous pouvez rendre cela clair pour vous-même en mettant les mots juste devant, grâce aux petits mots de notation mentale que Panté nous a proposés tout à l'heure.
Si il y a de l'inconfort dans les pieds, là, là-bas, il y a de l'inconfort.
Et s'il y a de l'inconfort dans les genoux, c'est là, là-bas, dans les genoux qu'il y a de l'inconfort.
Et s'il y a une émotion, c'est là-bas, là, qu'il y a dans la poitrine, dans l'estomac, cette émotion.
Et les pensées, les images, surviennent là, devant vous.
Tout est un objet.
Peut-être un objet.
Est-ce que celui qui perçoit peut être ce qui est perçu ?
Nous sommes dans ce poste d'observation à l'intérieur de nous-mêmes.
Nous pouvons nous apercevoir que toute chose survient par elle-même.
Le cœur offre des émotions que nous le voulions ou non.
Et l'esprit cherche tout le temps à essayer de penser.
Rien n'est sous notre contrôle direct.
Comment cela peut-il être moi ?
Mettons de côté toutes les instructions.
Ayons confiance dans cette conscience intuitive qui comprend de par elle-même.
Nous n'avons pas besoin de penser à quelque chose de particulier.
Just watch, just feel, just experience intimately.
Simplement regarder, ressentir, faire l'expérience intime.
Whatever draws our attention within the field of awareness.
Ce qui apporte, ce qui retient notre attention dans le champ de conscience.
Ne faites rien, ne changez rien.
Quand nous arrivons à la fin d'une assise, c'est bon de réfléchir un peu.
Est-ce que nous avons été diligents pour nous ramener au moment présent ?
Peu importe le nombre de fois où mon esprit a vagabondé, je l'ai simplement ramené gentiment à la respiration au corps.
Si je pense que mon effort a été plutôt vraiment constant, alors il faut que je me félicite.
Si je pense que j'aurais pu être plus diligent, alors il faut que je m'encourage.
Ne sors pas de la self-criticism.
Ne sombrez pas dans la critique de vous-même.
Comment avez-vous géré les différents états physiques et mentaux ?
Êtes-vous habile, malhabile, dans la confusion ?
Choisissez l'un de ces états.
L'agitation, l'esprit qui pense, qui s'obsède ou une grosse émotion.
Ou alors une douleur physique.
Si vous pensez que vous avez été habile, alors félicitez-vous.
Et si vous pensez que vous auriez pu être plus habile, alors vous vous encouragez.
Si vous étiez dans la confusion, alors il vous faut demander à l'enseignant.
Laquelle de ces trois caractéristiques de l'existence était la plus prégnante pour vous ?
Le processus du désir ?
L'impermanence ?
Ou que tout est un objet, pas sous notre contrôle direct ?
ou bien est-ce que c'était le fait que tout est un objet, pas sous notre contrôle direct ?